um a few a couple of years ago when the
Rice Museum um was closed before it
reopened in all its Splendor and glory
and the Treasures of the Rice Museum
were in an adjacent building it was
great that they were there it wasn't the
world's most impressive building but the
treasures were were there and as one
wandered through this great sequence of
Works verir in particular rembrand
ending with a nightwalk
out into the gift room uh the gift shop
inevitably um I noticed on the Till
There was a post there was a postcard of
The Girl With a Pearl Earring and a
notice saying no it's in the hag
which which which may or may not throw
light on the public um the public
opinion or mass opinion of visitors to
the Reich Museum um on tonight's debate
of course it doesn't um anyway I thought
I'd throw that into the mix um I I don't
know quite how tonight's debate is going
to go um I know that from brief
conversations with our speakers that you
know it may be a debate around Humanity
unedited in all its forms um to a kind
of self refle selfless reflection on The
Human Condition with space for the
viewer we may touch on light and dark we
may look at Del Amsterdam in contrast we
may look at scientific discovering and
an expressive form of art we may look at
religion um no jokes no jokes no no no
jokes um but um well it but it'll be
competive and competitive as you've seen
um just let me give you a brief uh run
through on the form this evening each of
the speakers will get 20 minutes I'm
giving them latitude to go to 23 but
we're going to try and be tight and
tough then there will be a a debate
between the three of us or the two of
them with me in the middle then there
will be time for questions from the
floor now you've all voted as you come
in we'll announce in the middle of the
evening what your vote was what the
entry poll was during the questions from
the floor um then the be it will be
announced that a Ballot Box is going
around and then you vote proper on the
debate you've all got these cards one
for rembrand one for verir you tear off
and put the relevant card into the box
if you're still undecided at the end of
the evening and that's your right put
the whole thing in and then after our
contributors have done their summaries
um we'll announce the debate we will
finish I promise you bang on half a
state um it's good manners and also it's
freeze week and you've all got
frightfully important things to go to
I'm quite sure okay first up Simon
Sharma um professor of history and art
history at Columbia University author of
17 books I think to date and Counting
everything from slavery to the history
of Britain to the history of the Jews
but also Rembrandt's eyes which has just
been republished by penguin tonight he's
Rembrandt's voice and for those of you
like me of course who can't get enough
of Simon um on Saturday night BBC 2 9:00
is his masterful program on Rembrandt's
late masterpieces which of course
coincides with the national gallery's
wonderful exhibition on late BR brand so
obviously the dice isn't firmly stacked
in Simon's favor I couldn't possibly say
anyway let him start 23 minutes on
rembrand starting
now thank you too no we don't have time
for that we so don't have time for
clapping barely have time for breathing
actually so he said to me he
said what are you out of your mind he
said to me in the usual nightmares I
have when I'm visited by R BR
approximately twice a week um he said
you know it's very asking Hannah K did
you bother to consult with me Sunshine
no so I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I
said as a matter of fact we both are
embarrassed I think speaking for Tracy
it uh Paul Valerie says you should
apologize before you speak of painting
and certainly neither of these two big
boys really need need our advocacy but
let's play the game CU something deep
who knows may come out of it namely in
to begin with what do we want from art
how do we think of the very greatest art
it could even be abstract art do we want
art essentially to be an edited version
of our own experienced human reality in
all its kind of sweat and dirt and flesh
and blood and craziness and passion as
well as its quiet tender moments do we
do we want that cleaned out do we want a
vision does is our supposed to give us a
vision of edited life then crystallized
in a beautiful cube of light if that's
what we want from art then verir is our
boy we do both need art both needs I
don't know about Tracy but I and this is
I've never done this in intelligence
Square debate but I will not go into
mourning if Mr verir of Del wins rather
than sorry Myan he's saying a fine
Advocate you are with friends like you
you know such but because art needs
Earth and it needs light but if you
think in the style of Shakespeare for
example that actually art should embrace
the magnitude of humanity all of it and
creates as William hlit said the genius
of REM BR was create something out of
nothing to actually change our minds
about what is ugly and what is beautiful
how art can transfigure the plain and
the decrepit and the ruined and the mled
and the paid and the poor as as well as
the rich and gorgeous and beautiful then
my big boy is your guy they're both in
their way very religious for of course
famously devoutly Catholic and when he
turned to Faith when he turned to se
Eternal matters God can we have less
light Gera what was gera's last words
Class M can I have less LIF actually or
maybe we can't do it can we not do it
Hannah maybe not okay don't won't waste
time on it but actually um maybe it's
better because you know slides are
slides go to the National Gallery and
everywhere but when vmir turned to
embody his faith in a late work so he
knew what he was doing he worked
essentially in algary what themir did
very beautifully I think actually is to
present you something that was closed
off in which you weren't you were given
this Exquisite crystalline penum of
shimmering light the light of the Gospel
in this particular case you had to
decode it in this atypical painting it's
quite true so the stands for something
and the snake stands for something else
heresy being crushed under the heel and
so on but when rembrand turned to faith
in this little picture and remember
Holland has been cleansed essentially of
icons in the name of Cal the calvinist
purity of churches this is what he did
it's in the church in France here we
have and of course it's you know um he
has in mind all those Christ before him
particularly Reuben is it was it was a
variation on a much grander painting of
Reuben's with whom rembrand had a kind
of LoveHate relationship both wanted to
emulate and stamp on Ruben's Head in
some ways as well what we got is a is a
is a little body broken in pain and
Christ literally howling with misery and
betrayal lama lama why why God have you
forsaken me if rbrand sometimes does as
Tracy's going to say feature rembrand
although the self-portraits are actually
a very tiny part of his Earth he
produced 350 paintings after all but
they're very very famous but if rbent
does actually feature himself and it's
thought that maybe one of an etching
actually was a model for the screaming
the howling pain tortured face of Christ
it's because not because he's an
egomaniac it's because Christian
doctrine wished True Believers to
identify body and soul with that broken
body of Christ is what happened at
Communion so in some sense rembrand
wants to be as all the great artists tra
Shakespeare Dante and someone wants to
be every man he's not one thing if you
want one thing brought to a pitch of
sublime consumation you'll go for verir
if you want somebody who can actually
not present himself but become part of
other people's experience including the
experience of the crucified Christ
you'll go to
rembrand rembrand also it's you know we
think quite rightly of verir as someone
who is you know no better painter ever
but of course what theia does is use his
brush as a lens we know he used the
camera obscurer the inverted reflection
was cast on the wall and from that came
the shimmering images which were
transcribed it's why David hotney and
everybody else tries unsuccessfully have
to say to imitate themir no one even has
the remote tarity to try and imitate
something like this this now look at
that the little oil sketch of hria
bathing sexy tender done probably just
for the two of them and tell me rembrand
is not in every sense technically as
stunning a brush Handler as verir but
but he uses he uses paints expressively
candidly Earthly he's he for example
look if you look at the her left her
excuse me her right hand on the left is
see it it's almost a kind of blur and
I'll come on to how am I doing
boss minutes okay um rembrand is you
know
astonishingly absolutely candid about
the fact that he's interested in using
the brush not as a lens not as a kind of
transcription of a scientific Vision but
as something which can actually generate
substance with the loaded brush with
pigment he is a kind of an extraordinary
Explorer of what the Lo loaded brush can
do and in his art are many many
different kinds of handling as you know
it was a famous test actually to be able
to do water that was you know in all the
academic textbooks in Dutch and
everything else as well water was
thought to be one of the great
challenges because when you do water
you've got to have actually a a sort of
translucent skin of the meniscus on the
surface but it needs to be it needs also
to be purely transparent inside so
remember says with these tiny little
perfectly visible Strokes of white I can
which which indicate exactly the Ripple
that Henri's legs are making as she's
feeling her way along this street I can
do that I can do reality in that way
then there are figures have you noticed
in verir not many old people around
actually not many old people not many
ugly people not many scarred people not
many kind of py people not many
different kinds of people even the
kitchen Maids are starlets
basically with curvy figures lir
wouldn't wouldn't have remotely occurred
vamir to make Margaretta the beautiful
her husband is dead her face the skin on
her face is so tight I'm sure it really
was that it reveals the preying skull
below and she knows she's not long for
this world before she actually um
actually joins her husband for this is
Rembrandt's meat and drink he TR
embodies the saying of Terren that
nothing human is alien to me and nothing
in that style was alien to the to the
making of beautiful art what V gives you
it seems to me are is are dreams are the
Visions we have in dreams of impossibly
perfect exquisitely glorious perfectly
colored visions of the kind it's sort of
basically a cross between a deep dream
that one's having in the middle of a a
beautiful dream and I don't know about
you a drug trip essentially as in that
of course one of the most glorious
paintings ever ever achieved it's Del
isn't it but this is what Del really
looked like Del had actually just
undergone a gigantic explosion in 1654
had it been completely rebuilt we know
from internal Chronicle evidence it most
certainly hadn't but what is verir he's
a good Catholic in a perfectly so of
course this is one of his many images of
Resurrection he repairs and why not we
want to believe in deled as Heaven
rebuilt the way it was before the fall
before the explosion which killed Harold
fortius this is one image of a city
rembrand it's not all he does but
rembrand knows he has a short life we
all do and he wants to do he wants to do
important things he wants not just to
say what is beautiful you know this
Exquisite Stillness of a j of milk he
wants to say what is our community he's
living they all are living in a tiny
country which is um a target of
Relentless military hatred by the French
by the Spanish so it's very important to
understand what binds you together and
to give it pictorial as well as boring
textual expression rbr will not steer
clear of that and it costs him dearly it
did not cost him dearly in the case of
the night watch but it might have done
it it took risks he's an incredible risk
taker he will do things he will fill up
his years not just be satisfied with 30
paintings however Exquisite during a
career so this is V's idea we have a
little gathering of basically Madam to
sword's wwor figures at the front
standing
there
halfway halfway to
Madness and this is Rembrant idea of a
city yes you know I I have to should we
all go through Amsterdam tomorrow
everyone I will irrespective of how it
all turns out tonight I will persuade
you all of you and there are thousands
of people who think this is the most
overrated painting do you think actually
ever to be declared a masterpiece it if
first of all you're seeing a bit of the
painting was much much bigger but the
point I want to make is all these people
gussed up in their fancy dress printing
be militia are free citizens we are not
like the regiments of the ridiculous
vile Catholic despots in France and
Spain we are free citizens and should
the duty Call we will shoot our muskets
and we will March forth um embodying
both our freedom and our determination
to die for our for our our country and
our Commonwealth and our city of
Amsterdam so it's chaotic it's chaotic
and that is the point it's the
centrifugal exploding chaos of Liberty
and what's happening to you everybody is
that the company of Fran Banning Co is
marching out of the picture frame it's a
3D painting right the axis in most
paintings which is like a freeze dummies
parallel to the picture plane is from
back to front and these figures are
Marching straight over anyone so inert
lazy cynical or apathetic not to answer
the call of their country in arms so
what happens to the painting we really
don't have time today is that it has to
represent this extraordinarily
risk-taking energy of formal composition
or freedom and at the same time be
tightly disciplined not fall apart
entirely and as a way by using this
great orthogonal s Andrew's cross design
in which R brand pins the composition
down hey freedom and Order Liberty and
discipline that's how the Dutch Will
Survive maybe if we're very very lucky
so the crystalline Cube the the camera
obscurer I think we'll leave him but I
just want you to notice from the great
chemwood it's fantastic to see how did
that happen Tim The Ivy bequest which
won't let anyone lean anything who was
blackmailing who it's now in the
National Gallery and it it's but go and
go back you know you can see it's just
hamson he this was the first REM ramp
painting I saw in the flesh and look at
it 1661 he's bankrupt he's three years
out of losing everything he had not just
his house not just a death of his wife
but also his entire huge art collection
his collection of paraphernalia the
stuffed armadillos the antique casts he
has carry all this around in his
enormous head it was his friend jeremus
DEA of whom he did a gorgeous portrait
which ought to have been don't want to
be chish ought to have been in the sh
National Gallery um from St Petersburg
who said oh rbrand I am merely a master
of words Deca being a poet but if I
tried to praise thee I would praise thy
Mighty nimble mind rembrand is not just
full of sentimental gush everybody he's
not just about passions and emotions he
is a formidable Mighty motor of thinking
but the thinking never feels like a
seminar it's said of late rembrand that
he couldn't draw he was indifferent to
drawing he was sort of apathetic really
he didn't care about the loose hand so
the two circles there um refer that's
taken at least 10 seconds and who knows
what it is um
um the two circles refer back in
Rembrandt's kind of professorial swatty
way to a story told by vasari about
jotto jotto is brought before the pope
and said the Pope says you think you're
good draw me something right away jotto
does this freehand Circle remat knows
that everybody knew vasar because it
have been translated into Dutch by Carol
Von Mander so he says can I draw mate is
look at the way I've done my hair my
nose and so on you know here's an
exercise in doing it he needed to
reassert his authority that it's not
again egomania but look everybody here's
what makes R special different he's an
experimentalist your if your eye in this
horrible slide can travel down to to the
the instruments of materially making the
art the
brushes the pallet the Mal stick and
that's a cute thing the Mal stick is
what you lean against the surface
uh in order to do refined detail the Mal
stick and look at his hands his hands
are this phenomenal were of
motion you won't see hands like that
again really till we get to
impressionism I think actually they're
kind of they they make a decision about
finish now the reason another reason I
want you to vote for big boy behind me
is
that far from being self-centered and
closed off everything R BR did
particularly in his late years was about
engaging you
us we do the finishing in our own mind
he is an old bastard in many ways he's
horrible to many people but he's the
most comradely of artists in his
sketches in his drawings it's profoundly
moving that he believes in the chamber
of imagination which will supply the
Finish you do a painting
roughly and then the viewer gets to
decide how smoothed out the details
might possibly be and there's one
painting I don't know I think I might
finish with this one actually how am I
doing you're doing fine okay seven
minutes this is painting
AAS have you seen this in In the Flesh
he won't let anyone see it now this is a
painting of a man called Yan 6 and the
painting is now owned by someone called
Yan 6 the baron young 61 hom and it used
to be the case that you could get a
little ticket at rank Museum and go down
the Road and see it and you can't do
that anymore but um here's what I want
to show you I think it was on okay look
at that is that man or whatever what is
that that's a 17th Century painter
that's not verir this is someone who was
actually showing you what brush work can
do allowing you and there's a reason for
this he's not just doing it to show
off why okay yanix is a friend slightly
fair weather friends it turned
out remember I was not great in repaying
loans young Yan had an
IOU and yeah and so but he's he comes
from a family of
ders of cloth Merchants who are ders and
what Rembrant was wonderful at no
painter in the history of of of this
period of art had a gift for empathy
not a gift for egotism but a gift for
empathy understanding what the patrons
wanted he sometimes ran ahead of the
patrons and got into terrible trouble as
with the great Claudia civilist with a
town hall but every effort he could make
was to do this and he paid just as he
pays us the compliment of finishing the
work in our own head and our own eyes he
paid his patrons the compliment of
saying I I have a sense of how you want
to be and the patrons are say goodness
that you were so right that's exactly
how I wanted to be so this is the second
generation of a rich D hence this cape
which when you go and see it if you go
and see it but even if you look at it in
my book is the most ey piercing
Vermillion Scarlet you will ever see
it's not that wretched color on the on
on all reproductions so he's wearing his
inventory he's wearing his family
history but Yan 6 is also a poet as his
remant in his way and Yan wrote a play
called Meda rant was hired to do a FR p
and fr P for it and so YK said I'm not
all about money the Dutch all say it
we're not about money we're about
reflection we about inwardness and the
Glorious thing about Rembrandt at this
moment when his fortune is very
difficult is he turns from an exuberant
street life you know the great Playboy
of Amsterdam really the show off the man
who thinks he's tishan and rubben and
rapael and all the rest of it into
inward thoughtfulness but it's a
thoughtfulness that is in flesh and
blood so the shadow falling over again
it's a very deep Shadow much deeper than
that is the sort of sign of poetic
reflection but Yan 6 is carrying this
complicated baggage um he's posed by
rembrand exactly between the street and
the house hence he's putting on or
possibly taking off a glove look at the
glove the glove again is painted with
Sensational daring that glove is in
motion everything in the appears to rest
everything V is about
crystallization rembrand is about
animation human animation so that glove
is a whirl of undetermined paint and
most of all the frogging the greatest
frogging I probably not a big frogging
competition in the history of art but
that would win it okay just a brush
loaded a hog bristle brush loaded so
much with that yellow pigment the
bristles separate and it is of course a
REV demonstration of painting there's
there's the detail of the glove and
there's the detail
of of what Ram brand does with it what
but you see it and it's extraordinary
this isn't seen as a revolutionary
moment in the entire history of Western
painting which is exactly what it is
I've got like one minute
left
okay I think that's going to finish well
okay here's hand on a breast it's verir
here's hand on a breast it's rembrand
you
choose I want to do one final
image that one talk of revolutions
rembrand is the only person to whom it
occurs there is a complicated psychology
everybody when a man looks at a woman
there's a fantastically funny moment in
in in the actually not terrible
Alexander cord film biopic where Charles
Lon and Charles Lorton looks at hria
stles play Bosa Lanchester and um and
then he brings her in and you know and
then he he puts her on a chair and she's
very self-conscious and he goes you
don't have to worry my dear it's all
about
art and in fact of course the nude is an
entitlement for the male gays Rembrant
sees Rembrant no feminist at all sees
there is a subtle complication there
he's done Freedom he does human
animation he does the relationship
between Sexes so in a series of of
etchings which are all laid out
beautifully in the exhibition we see a
model between takes we see a real woman
who is not a nude who is recovered in
Rembrandt's image as a woman entire a
woman who is cold who is warming herself
by the
stove art ultimately uh reality
ultimately crashes into Arts the mighty
marriage between art and human truth is
one that rembrand and only rembrand
[Applause]
made so that's um crystallization
against animation rembrand strip bear
isn't it brilliant that a man who
accuses the other artists of taking
drugs actually started by saying that
rembrand speaks to him still that's one
of
those great things that we might draw in
later um now verir um Tracy shali is
doesn't really need an introduction but
she's the the author of seven novels um
whose subjects artistically range from
medieval tapestries to William Blake
slavery and of course um the M go with
the Pearl Earring is um it was her
second novel published in 1999 it sold
four million copies worldwide and still
counting it's also the subject of a best
selling film with Scarlet Johansson and
Colin fth so here to make the case of
Air Tracy
chaler Simon it's like uh listening to
you is like looking at a rembrand
painting now thank you so much for
giving us your Insight and your passion
about rembrand I feel like you're uh
riding a giant rembrand wave that's
crashing onto London this week and we've
chosen today which happens to be the day
that the late rembrand uh show opens in
the National Gallery so there's this
huge sloshing of rembrand all over the
place and um I don't want to get knocked
down by it but I think I'm starting here
a little verir under
toe so that's what's happening but with
all of your knowledge I thought you
might be able to help me out um I've
been thinking this week so you can think
about this while I'm
talking um I've been thinking this week
about where in the world you can
actually see stand in a room and see a
rembrand and a verier at the same time
now I can only think of one place and
that's London Kenwood house which is
probably where you saw the uh the late
Ren Brandt first when you were young and
um I can't think of any place else so
maybe you can have a little think and if
we can come up with something at the end
we can there aren't many there ah in the
same
room in the same room most places have a
verier and a rembrand but they're in
different rooms so Kenwood house is a
good place for me to start because
because of this possibly unique
proximity of a rembrand and a vermier in
the same room
but also because I live near it I'm very
familiar with Ken woodh house I go there
all the time I pop in I have a look at
the vermier I have a look at the
rembrand too and um and then I go and in
fact when I was riding girl with the
earli earing back in
1998 I used to get stuck and then I'd
walk across the heath to clear my head
inevitably I'd end up at Kenwood house
I'd go in I'd see the verier and that
would unblock me me somehow and then I'd
go back and write some more so I have a
real fond spot uh place in my heart for
that particular room in Kenwood
house now when you go into that room if
you turn right and then you turn right
you see this well actually you don't see
this at the moment because of the
National Gallery at this exhibition but
if you go back at next May you'll see it
again in its place it is a late I
thought it was very late I thought that
he had finished painting it in 60 9 I
they still they're giving poor
information in various places I won't
say where though but um it's a late
rembrand and the thing about it is I I
stand in front of it and I look at the
beautiful beautiful brush work that's so
loose you can see it's almost like a
painting in progress and the brown of
his of his robe and the white of his cap
the cream I love that um so I stand and
and most of all of course we all look at
his face because his face is just has
his whole life in it he doesn't hide
anything it's wartz and all he has been
through love and so much loss he has
been incredibly popular he's going into
debt he's got it all there it's a very
rembrand face if you know what I mean
apart from it being him it really is
shows a person in all of his naked
rawness especially his eyes I see those
eyes all the time of H dark really just
getting you they're getting you they're
pinning you and there's so much sadness
in those eyes I'm got to come back to
those eyes so I look at the painting and
then I walk catty corner across the room
to this painting this is vermeer's
guitar player from 1672 so several years
after or 10 years 11 years after the REM
rant this this is a very quintessential
vermier um and it's not even his best
but it has all of the elements that you
associate with vermier it's got a lot of
yellow and blue in it he loved those
colors he used them a lot it's a woman
on her own doing something in a in a
room with light coming from one side
usually the light is coming from the
left in this case it's coming from the
right I love looking at this painting
for her left hand that is amazing
painting work right there those fingers
I just think they're Divine the
uh cloth here all around her knee he
just renders those folds of the satin
beautifully and I find when I'm in that
room that I spend a lot longer in front
of this painting than I do the rembrand
uh now yeah okay it could be because I
know more about vermier and I like verir
or better but I think it's something
else why is it that I'm so attached to
looking at him why do I spend longer in
front of of a vermier than a rembrand
well I think there are three reasons
that are all sort of overlapping that
I'm going to go into the first one let's
go back to
rembrand this painting is one of many I
think 40 self-portraits um now vermier
painted 36 paintings so we're already uh
rembrand has painted more self-portraits
than vermier is painting paintings and
that's not even all they there is a
whole category of paintings that are of
rembrand who has put himself in
paintings that are of something else so
he used himself as a Model A lot and I
don't even know if we should bother to
make that distinction CU frankly when
you look at a rembrand that has people
in it they're all rembrand they all look
exactly like rembrand you see those sad
straight eyes staring out at you all of
his people people even when they're
named portraits to me look like a a
member of the of the rembrand family and
uh when Rembrandt
paints he's painting himself over and
over and over again and it feels like
he's there he's exposing himself in all
of his painterly glory and he's saying
this is me and you're not
invited now re verier had a very
different idea about what a painter is
and what a painter should be to the
viewer we only can think of really two
times when verier painted himself if
that we're not sure there's so little
known about him that it's almost
impossible to tell the first is this I
love this image he's got his back to us
he's wearing red stockings in fact I'll
show you the whole painting this is
called the art of painting it's from
1666 67 its midcareer
um verier has created this Tableau of
here's what painting is like and what he
does is he goes to his dress up box and
he and he gets out some clothes and said
I'm going to dress up as an artist today
he's wearing a black Beret see he's
wearing a a black dublet with slit
sleeves and back no artist wore that
when he was actually painting this is
the idealized vision of an artist he's
placed himself with his back to us he's
wearing red stockings I think that's
what is real the real piss take here is
that he just isn't serious about the the
vision he has of himself or he doesn't
want us to take it too seriously he
doesn't want to be in our way what he's
doing is he's stepping aside literally
stepping back into the painting so that
we can step forward and and engage with
it more fully with rembrand with the
with a self-portrait it is me and you
are out there here rembrand is beckoning
come in now to be completely Fair he did
paint another portrait possibly of
himself an earlier one where he is
facing
forward there he is in an early painting
called the procuress ah the breast
painting yes hand on breast we're coming
back to that this is an early vermier
from 1656 six he was 24 years old he was
still trying to figure out what his
style was going to be and what his
subject was going to be and this is a a
a portrait as a a Dutch genre painting
um the young woman in yellow is uh being
courted by well courted in in uh quotes
by the man in red probably a soldier
he's got a coin he's got his hand on her
breast we know what's going to happen
next this has all been brought about by
the the old woman in the back the
procuress she's basically pimping the
young woman in Dutch genre painting of
the time the tradition was if you have
somebody on the side looking out when
everybody else isn't looking out that's
often a self-portrait of the painter and
here he again is in his his dress up
costume as an artist raising his glass
looking very marry and this is an early
verir that frankly if you if I didn't
tell you as a vermier probably wouldn't
know it was it's not what we think of as
the vermier the master this is a young
painter still finding his feet still
trying to figure out what he's going to
do but his vision of the painter is not
to the four it's not to the front it's
as almost as a jokey character to the
side again we're invited to come a
little
closer this is 1656 something happened
to vermier right after that I want you
to keep keep your eyes on the woman in
yellow and
watch now it might be the same model it
might not be this woman in yellow is
completely completely different from the
perus and the vision the way vermier
painted changed now we don't know why
it's possibly because um uh some art
historians suggest it's because he used
a camera of you're starting around this
time either to view painting uh to to to
set up or even to paint by if you've
seen the film Tims vermier that takes it
to an extreme but uh certainly something
happened and uh a camera obscura uh
focuses uh light and it focuses color so
the colors become more intense and some
of the focus the what you see through a
lens some things are more in Focus some
out of focus but even more importantly
and this becomes the uh brings me to the
second reason why I think I prefer
vermier to rembrand First R verier has
stepped aside and let me to get up close
to the painting now he's inviting me
into the painting this is what I call
the Transcendence of the everyday he's
found his subject matter and the subject
matter is what goes on in our daily
lives it's not about Greek mythology
which he painted it's not biblical
scenes which he painted early in his
career it's not genre scenes which are
trying to push some moral agenda this is
the Transcendence of the everyday it's
making something we do pouring milk
beautiful it's making it sexy I hope I
look like that when I'm pouring milk in
the
morning other paintings we think of of
vermier making his um his quintessential
paintings are of usually of women on
their own in a corner the light coming
in from the left doing something for
from the every day so they're either
putting on a necklace playing a loot
weighing gold like did that back in um
or uh reading a letter or pouring milk
all of those things that we can step in
and say yeah I know what that's like I
pour milk every day I read letters all
the time we feel like we're being
invited in not only that vermier puts a
lot of effort into the detail into the
everyday detail of the paintings you
don't notice it you don't see the brush
work and the way rembrand shows off with
brush work but here you see the little
dots of white paint along the handle of
the basket and on the bread itself it
makes it look like a table full of
jewels so
beautiful in another painting of a
similar time from 1657 just before
before the milk made but also probably
using a camera obscura this is called a
young woman reading at an open window
reading a letter and again it's
Exquisite and it's it's privileging the
everyday when I look at it I think yes
maybe my life my banal cian life is
actually more beautiful and interesting
than I thought this gives me that
permission what verier also does here is
he puts things in the foreground so he's
he's put put a a curtain in the
foreground which he sort of pulled back
it makes it look almost theatrical that
there's this intimate thing this
intimate moment that we're spying on
he's pulled back that curtain but he's
placed a table in the front so it holds
us back so that she's in the background
of the painting and we are drawn into
the foreground by the subject matter so
we're inside the painting but we're not
quite with
her now the Third reason we've had
vermier step aside out of the painting
out of the subject he's allow he's he's
allowed us to step into the painting and
become part of the everyday life the
third reason is his
universality now you didn't think I was
going to go on and on without talking
about Girl With a Pearl Earring of
course this is a painting from 1665 to
66 midc career
and it is an amazingly Universal
painting it's not just that we've seen
the image all over the place it's not
just that it's more that vermier has
taken something that looks very specific
and made it Universal this is not
actually a portrait it's not meant to be
somebody who you recognize who you can
identify it's what they call in Dutch a
Tron a Tron means in Dutch face it's
like a type he's he's painted a type of
person so trony can be something like
the Drinker or The Gambler or the artist
or here the beautiful young girl um this
what he's the way he's done it is by
taking all of the things that we think
um would make us know a person and strip
them away so if you look at if you look
at the girl you can't tell what color
her eyes are um sometimes they look
green sometimes they look brown or gray
I know I've studied them a lot and I
even asked the woman who restored the
painting for the 1995 exhibition in the
heg what color her her eyes were and she
said I don't know it's impossible to
tell you can't tell what color her hair
is it's all hidden away you can't really
tell what the shape of her face is
because she's turned it to the side you
can't even tell what the shape of her
nose is because that line Blends right
into the cheek so you can't tell is it
thin nose is it a bulous nose who knows
all of those those cues that we normally
get to be able to scan a face to put an
identity to it have been Stripped Away
as a result everybody thinks they know
somebody looks like her I have had
hundreds of emails from people writing
to me saying I love this painting
because my aunt looks like this painting
I love this painting because my daughter
looks like this painting and here's a
photo of her see doesn't she look like a
girl with a pear earring and I go well
she doesn't but I know what you mean and
a reader even once said to me Tracy I
think you wrote that book because you
look like girl with the Pearl earing I
thought flattery will get you everywhere
how many books do you want me to sign
that was
fabulous but it's because all of the
specifics have been Stripped Away so it
feels Universal so not not only has
vermier stepped out of the canvas not
only has he invited us in he's actually
invited us inside the painting so that
we can turn around and actually become
girl with a PR earring if you go on the
internet there are hundreds of photos of
women and a few men who have dressed
themselves up as girl with a
pear beautiful
beautiful and why not what other
painting I'm sorry but you don't go on
uh on the internet and find people
dressed up as rembrand it just doesn't
happen I'm really sorry sorry Simon and
there's no they don't dress up as rbrand
paintings either you start son's web
page not only are we invited to step in
because it's so Universal we think we
know her and that we are her we step in
we turn around and then we decide we're
going to make it something we're going
to make it our own painting So if we
want want a zombie girl with a Pearl
Earring we've got
one
now this is a great painting and it's
great in so many ways but one of them is
that it's a it's
a vermier has managed somehow to make
this specific to to make something feel
familiar and yet utterly mysterious
there's so many questions I have about
this woman what's her name who is she
how old is she is she happy or sad what
is she thinking I've written a whole
book about her and I still don't
know now I would never dream of saying
that vermier is a better painter than
Rembrandt I'm it would be fool hearty to
do it especially with Simon here um and
it would be like comparing apples and
pears so I'm not going to do that but I
will say that I think that looking at a
vermier painting is more satisfying
experience experience than looking at a
rembrand rembrand is painting for
rembrand vermier is painting for us
thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you Serene really and there's a kind of
method isn't there in the way that both
of our speakers are approaching their
subject matter um before we start the
debate um I've got the results of the um
intro poll as it were as you came in so
31% of you voted for
rembrand 30% of you voted for the
m and 39% of you don't
know close right um Simon do you want to
respond to this um this idea that
rembrand is all about the self and that
verir is the the generous Spirit who
invites Us in and resonates universally
yeah that's the main point um I I was
really kind of baffled by that I mean I
um maybe my eyesight's worse than I
thought but I couldn't see any
resemblance between R BR and Yan 6
whatsoever or 95% of all his ciens so
you know the the reason and I was going
to show the great Nicholas Rootz from
the frck where he also is invested in
inhabiting the fur Merchant really so he
almost looks like one of the little foxy
little Sables that he does so what is
often said about REM brand I agree is it
had an extraordinary capacity to
actually um make him you know to to find
himself in the psychology of of the
sitters um you know the the the group
portraits as well which are about very
important things the anatomy listen of
Dr tulp is about the relationship
between dexterity of one kind the
dexterity of the an atomist deting a
body and the dexterity of the painter
both of them god-given so but when you
look at that extraordinary electrifying
painting it's really rembrand dissolving
his personality inside the ethos of the
group if you go even to the synex the
style mters the beautiful painting
that's really um that's hanging in the
exhibition at National Gallery he has to
do a really difficult thing these are
quality control inspectors sitting at a
table posing for their portrait you know
not a boardroom meeting not a thrilling
subject but he makes the effort he's not
he makes the effort essentially um to
think about the relationship between
what they do in other words is this is
this cloth good enough to be proudly
represent the best that Holland could do
and he gives this extraordinary sense of
dynamism actually in the group so far
from him you know he painted right 40
paintings he paint there 400 paintings
that's 10% of the output but you you
honestly Tracy what you know what I
don't get is the notion that when he
looks at himself it's in any sense vain
or self-absorbed it's brutally self-
scrutinizing it's sort of lacerating in
its ruthless cander yes um so you know
he
mayed why did he paint himself so much
it seems to me like 10% of your output
is a lot of of painting yourself and
also more than that there's so many
times when he puts himself in the
painting no no that's well that's
strictly factually wrong tell me more
than two pardon tell me more than two
where he puts himself inside the
painting there's the racing of the
crossing of the Cross night watch one
eye in the night watch why not one eye
in the night watch I said more than two
it's not play himself it's it's that he
uses his his own face uh in various
paintings
simply not true no he's interested in
the great you know human comedy the
theater no one paints more different
kinds of human beings than rembrand with
all his dazzling Brilliance and Beauty
the cast of characters in verir is a
tiny soap opera of Domesticity yes it's
a it's a focus it's a even the
prostitute really looks like someone who
can't stop you know I mean she she's
Gorge piece of cosmetically designed
aure rembrand you smell the street yes
but that gets a little exhausting after
a while he doesn't do it all the time he
does it a lot look at the hria bathing
picture that's not just about dirt and
rawness and it's not you know it is his
lover and a more tender picture of a
lover you can never imagine what about
age I mean verir we think was about 43
when he died that's roughly the we know
R was 63 um 20 years extra that
shouldn't I mean obviously that's um
tough really in this Cent terms of the
debate he had 20 years extra that may
play out with our audience but do you
think that I mean Simon seems to be
arguing that age actually is where Ramat
becomes at his most profound um you seem
to be arguing by implication that
actually it's the freshness the Vitality
the univ the universality but do you see
it as as a significant disadvantage but
it's something you need to deal with the
fact that he he painted so few and he
died young yeah I think the fact that he
paid painted so few is is actually in
his favor it it um because there's so
few you appreciate them more I agree
with that you go you can't i' I've seen
all of verz there are to see have you
seen every rembrand it's just impossible
there's so many of them and it gets
exhausting after a while and the thing
about rembrand is that he didn't he
didn't get a chance to self- select in a
way because he he painted so much
well
and unable and he has terrible off has
terrible off days and almost in his
prime never has an off day be honest
prier does have off days he um he
doesn't paint hands very well except for
the guitar player there's some he does
some awful gaps but we all do but the
fact that there were so many fewer and I
think I think that he painted slower
more slowly he took a lot more time on
uh canvases you can see that in his his
brush Strokes are very carefully done
and if he did use a camera obca it would
it slowed it down even more so there is
this feeling of less is more and that's
what I love about him is that that
concentrated Focus that he doesn't do
these broad except for the view of Del
which is really the only place where he
widens out it's always in that focused
corner of his Studio that you see the
same wall and the same hangings and the
same women over and over again and yet
each one feels like a jewel and slightly
different it's that it's the taking the
Focus like that where you actually allow
yourself to expand what is there see REM
bran uh all that's true I don't you're
absolutely right about that REM what I
think is record that
no it is what is bizarre is to represent
rembrand as someone who's not interested
in the people who's kind of closed off I
don't get that Invitational thing as
well countless rbrand in which you know
the whole direction of the way he's
organized space is design and more
importantly it's not just rembrand but
other people who rembrand beautifully
conveys who do indeed are not kind of
Shifty and masked in Shadow and in
profile some of them is beautiful things
always in profile rembrand is interested
in what happens when your eyes out there
meet my eyes he's interested in that
weird sometimes sexy sometimes
disturbing sometimes irritable
Transaction what I wanted to say Tim was
that it's incredibly important REM
Brand's a
printer you know rembrand as you'll see
and I in a way the National Gallery show
is kind of funny but I really beg you
even though it's very hard and this is
not to do with the debate or winning
points it's it's to enjoy this stunning
Exhibition at National Gallery you know
how difficult it is when there's a crowd
in there and there's a people
everybody's craning please please take
the effort to do so because there are
some extraordinary etchings in that and
the etching not all of them but the
etching is a way of producing multiples
to reach a public rembrand is theatric
terrible theatrical ham he's he wants to
be loved he makes it very difficult to
be loved he's above all interested in
the diffusion of his art to a public
he's also interested in he's an
extraordinary draftsman as you know the
drawings talk about less is more the
winter landscape in the fog which I'm
sure you know is like three lines and
somehow is a Universe of a snow covered
Village so he can't stop he does suffer
from a kind of some vitous dance of
multitasking in every conceivable medium
he possibly can and he will have he will
make mistakes what I love it is an
opposite temperament it is an opposite
temperament for vmir who felt if there
were mistakes in vmir we'll never know
about them and that's a kind of lovely
thing there are no drawings there's not
any s of CRA perfectionist we know so
little about him I I sometimes feel like
Rembrandt's
biography swamps him whereas verir we
know nothing about well we only have
seven letters by I feel like that allows
me to into the paintings more easily
because I don't have to I don't have a
name on the the on the the it's not a
portrait of somebody it's it's a type
and so it allows me in there's there's
space there to breathe and to be a
little calmer whereas reman is just look
at all this paint look at it all whereas
verir just Smooths it out you very
rarely see it every now and then you see
a little detail where he's let himself
go a bit and because everything else
isn't Let Go I mean do you know the red
hat the girl in the red hat the National
Gallery Washington possibly a possibly a
verir y but it may not be a same amazing
red uh paint and the lace maker in the
Lou this tiny Jewel of a painting where
the lace coming out of this little box
uh the the the bits of embroidery thread
are just done in this wonderful snarl of
kind almost impressionist style painting
and you go wow and yet the rest of the
painting is so controlled that it makes
that little bit when he lets go you just
go yes and it's it just whereas reman I
just feel like it lets go too much it's
just like it's like diarrhea almost you
could almost
say you really going to wish you hadn't
said that let's not go down that way I
know he he a lot of his paintings are
brown but that's you know it's not the
same thing it's funny the the American
painter Chuck Close always windes me up
by saying he thinks Rembrandt's an
Exquisite Ester and drawer but he says
the paintings are gravy but never
diarrhea I have to say it is sort of
stomach churning um I mean I think one
of the problems and one of the
liberating factors of a debate like this
for you all is um I'm not giving you the
parameters of how you're going to make
your decision it may be the sum total of
achievement um is going to favor one
artist who live longer and produce a lot
more work or it may be that your
decision has to be made on hitting the
Heights and that one painter can
actually win a debate because that's
what all artists in the end are working
for from one work to the next to the
next or even if they're making a series
it's always this quest for some kind of
unattainable perfection that's up to you
I'm going to throw it out to you in
about two minutes but I just wanted to
bring religion bring it all down bring
religion or bring it up um into the
debate again because you both site
religion very strongly and I know Simon
that one of your things about rembrand
is bearing witness you know he's the
quintessential Protestant painter for me
interesting isn't it because you say
he's a devout Catholic but he becomes a
Catholic I think he's born a Protestant
but he becomes a Catholic in order to
marry his in order to marry his wife so
let's just have a a few I mean you know
we know that the rubben rembrand debate
is always won in this country by
rembrand because fundamentally we're not
a Catholic country or a counter-reform
country um but just just some some
observations about religion in this in
this debate and how it pans out is ran
brand always at an advantage in Britain
because he's a Protestant yeah probably
I mean I'm not sure rbrand is we we'll
find out tonight but I I'm actually not
sure rembrand is at an advantage over
verir in in Britain at all I think verir
plays exquisitly to the kind of mania
for understatement which um uh which is
you know our national condition which
always makes me astounded that I've had
any kind of career at all you
know but I will say I will say about I
will and you're abely right Tim we've
wonderfully kind of impersonated The
Temper of our of Our Heroes what I want
to say about rembrand this why I showed
that not very wellknown beautiful cross
in a French church is that for what
rembrand took very seriously not not as
an orthodox calvinist which he really
wasn't his mother actually was a
Catholic um and but he joins a group
called a colians who are kind of sort of
like Dutch Quakers not exactly and the
cians all know Hebrew and they're quite
close to Jews another another reason you
know it's very hard to imagine the
hanging out with Jews I have to say he's
so white you know um but uh remand is
very interested in religion embodied
inside us walking the streets with us
when you go to the National Gallery and
we are going to check up on you to make
sure that you do you will see a famous
Bartholomew and aeti which everybody
can't believe that and he looks like a
kind of middle level bank manager
doesn't he he's got a short hair and a
mustache looks like a 19th century
that's tough on St Bartholomew I think
um and the reason is that for rembrand
of course you know who lives in a Jewish
neighborhood but who hangs out with all
sorts of nobbly faed people in Amsterdam
we all carry the possibility of biblical
Transfiguration around with us and that
is uh extraordinarily moving the very
last painting he did almost certainly I
there were two that viin I was going to
show the prodical son in the Hermitage
um that is an incredible painting where
um I was going to say the other
Contender I'll say very very quickly is
in the show again National Gallery it's
of Simeon with the Christ child and it
is this old blind man who remember kind
of made blind remember in father was
blind and the light is coming out from
baby Jesus um in a kind of great
explosion a kind of spray he's almost
it's some he got a spray P very very
powdery and granular paint it is the
most extraordinarily moving thing and
these are commonplace faces the baby is
a fat chubby Street baby from Amsterdam
and the other the other Contender is the
prodical Son and you don'ts one time
where again he's not doing faces
actually uh Tracy where in 1669 the last
year the father again prodical son is
made to be blind you'll all know this
he's leaning on his son and you do not
see the face of the protocal son in this
case I completely um except Tracy's
point it's kind of Rarity to actually do
the strategy of the hidden in this case
it's hidden the protal son kneels before
his father his head is Shor very badly
his clothes are falling off him and what
you see at the center of the painting
are upturned shredded lacerated soles of
his feet that was REM Brand's
religion vermier um was born Protestant
he he um be we think he became Catholic
in order to marry his Catholic wife and
um the T the three paintings I can think
of that have religious content two were
early one was St Barbara and the other
was um Mary and Mary and Martha um and
then the late painting that Simon showed
at the beginning which is actually
really hi hideous painting and the two
early uh biblical scenes I don't think
much of either it was before vermier
came into his own um and I think that he
uh was blessed with being able to not
having not being expected to um paint
biblical scenes because he much
preferred Domesticity and in fact the
Dutch feeling of the time the Dutch uh
Dutch middle class that was growing at
that time in the 17th century during the
Golden Age wanted to see themselves
reflected um in paintings rather than
biblical scenes and so he was able to
indulge that and I think what he does is
he as I me said before he takes the
every day and he makes it more
Transcendent more special and there is
something quite religious in that in
that feeling there's a there's a Madonna
like feeling about a lot of the women
and I but I think that's the extent it's
a very it's a very personal religious
feeling rather than a public one I
remember Tom Paulin saying that he
thought the woman pouring milk this was
on newsight review he thought this was
about the Eucharist and
transubstantiation but that maybe says
more about Tom than it does about verir
but it's interesting in the everyday
right now let's throw it to the floor
I'm going to take questions in batches
let's start with a couple of questions
and then we'll do them in threes could
you wait till the microphone is with you
cuz we're recording this um other
question who are the question there's a
a lady here in the foreground at third
row and then yeah that that's great so
first yeah I was just wondering if you
talk about the influence that each
artist had on AR history of art sub so
I keeper that
bigpress and explosion
and when I look at Premier I think about
James or Richard Prince and you know a
lot of
thee great thank you that's good right
we hold that and then second question oh
right my question is about light really
I I it was interested that I was
expecting Tracy to talk about B's light
really and and that difference between
um Rembrandt's light and M's light and I
wondered how much you thought his light
was dependent on the lens and when the
lens well how important it was uh to the
great well I won't be too crashing try
and bring them together but it's still
an interesting thing about impact I mean
you know you could say that Donald Jed
or Dan flaven have been influenced by
that late or not let's let's let's
wrestle with the influence but think
about light too Simon well um you know
uh it's tough onir because he goes
missing for so long you know AAS and and
ridic ridiculously and has to be
discovered so with rembrand rembrand is
never not famous um there are constant
arguments about rembrand whether he was
self-indulgent and his loose handling of
pain um but he's he's not only not never
famous which isn't you know necessarily
to his credit um but he's never not a
subject of conversation and um where was
the lady who's yeah so so he is always
on the agenda for example um you know
Reynolds Joshua Reynolds who one thinks
of as an extraordin really unlikely
candidate to be a rembrand admirer um
and has actually mixed feelings but
there are some passages for example the
ber the that actually pressy alluded to
the kind of heavy creamy um application
of pain on headdresses kind of thing
that um that Reynolds comments on and
everybody does you know the French in
particular when the railway station
makes it out to Amsterdam in the 1840s t
t and tul gutier and people like that
actually see REM bran as as an as
someone who expanded what painting can
do he and rightly or wrongly Turner for
example is a kind of boted admirer for
obvious reasons of rembrand um they see
that rembrand can actually make paint
live in its own right without any loss
of realism in a way without any without
being deceiving as to the truth of
Nature and that sets that you know
extraordinary generation in the middle
of the 19th century especially in France
but including Turner the barbazan school
and um and kurb in particular who are
going to you know queue up impressionism
on a radical New Path I I was I was CR
much criticized size for all sorts of
reasons but when REM BR SI came out for
over modernizing REM brand
anachronistically and I I was sort of
impenitent and remain impenitent I don't
see how you can look at the Yan
for example and not say that actually
that was a radical revolution in the way
in which a portrait could be conceived
and executed which had profound
influence on on the making of modernism
if you look at the explosion of
self-portraiture which has become the
self has moved more and more Center
Stage as one Trend Trend in art over the
last century and a half you could blame
or credit REM with that yes and I I
absolutely agree that's right it's blame
or credit if you like Lucian Freud it's
like or Frank arbach but particularly
Lucian Freud you're likely to be a a rem
branum because Freud likeed to say um uh
I I don't paint likenesses I make the
paint create the body never a shrinking
violet probably even less than than
rembrand but you could see really how
the build of paint and rembrand was
fascinated in what he could do with the
texture of pigment unlike verir so when
you look at the Jewish bribe which I had
to absurdly kind of just skimp over you
know we we have a nice sequence to in in
the little film on Saturday it's
extraordinary things you find in that
paint you find silica sand bits of crush
glass eggshell egg substance um clay I
mean and REM of course actually again
unlike verir and it is a big stage act
in painting Trac is absolutely right
about that if you look at the Aristotle
if you look rembrand is interested in
sculptural ulation of paint so beads and
warts and crusts and ponds in some
paintings for example the National
Washington National Gallery M uh
lucrecia breathtaking tragic Masterpiece
in the show he will give you this
immense crust mantling crust of pigment
on her on her dress in order that her
flesh and she's just committed she's
about to commit suicide the open neck of
her shift in order to do that he will
thin the paint out to practically
watercolor so for him every painting was
an adventure about exploring every
conceivable thing that paint could do
yeah enough of this pu puffing and
plugging but but there's a show at the
Royal Academy in January that will make
the claim about Ruben sorry over to you
my answer is going to be a lot
shorter uh vermier disappeared and
reemerged um in 1866
in France and it took a century for his
reputation to build up so he hasn't been
he hasn't had that kind of influence
that you've been asking about on as as
rembrand would have on Contemporary Art
but where he has had a big influence is
on contemporary photography I see a lot
of um vermier mon out there and and
photography but the the best
photographer um doing this now is uh Tom
Hunter who's a British who sets up he's
done a series of um of of photographs of
squatters in positions of taking vermier
paintings and setting them up so that
you have uh the woman reading the letter
uh that I showed earlier you have a
woman reading an eviction notice and
it's um a baby it's really beautiful so
there's a lot of um there's that sort of
hyper realism use use of um of of V
visual techniques does that come back to
to the L's point there about light and
lenses I mean using contemporary
technology and therefore he's he's a
he's an artist who resonates with those
in the last 150 years he want to keep
using contemporary technology I think
yes and it certainly um ties in with the
more the with the the rise of
Photography as as an art form um and I
would love to seen what verir would have
made of of a camera a real camera not a
camera obscura but a camera I mean he
certainly used the camera obscura but
what how would he have and it's very
much about how things are set up so I
think um but you you you make my point
for me because actually what rembrand
does is is do what photography can't do
with pain hold that you can come back
three three more questions
well yeah there's a a woman at the back
there hand up sorry I don't want to at
the top
yeah um if if you think about the Golden
Age it was the beginning of uh
individualism and a heightened capacity
for complexity and emotional complexity
and also a perspective complexity would
it be fair to say that you could say
this was happening both in Rond and Fier
one was more internally emotional
richness respecful view of of the in
interior and the other was more exterior
putting the human being in this massive
magn magnificent light with all the
complex uh complexity of perspective in
that okay emotional complexity I
couldn't have said it better myself
absolutely
so try claim it wasn't really a question
but if it was the answer would be yes
you're absolutely SP
onest I love the fact you're both
agreeing so neither of you are going to
take that territory so it's a oneall
draw in that respect right next question
next
question well while you're thinking I
can't believe that what about this
risk-taking idea then I mean Simon says
that Rembrandt's the great risk taker by
implication verir can't be or isn't as
much a risk taker do you do isn't as
much of a risk taker that was one of
your points that that's why we should go
with I think uh he doesn't take risks as
often in paintings but I I think girl of
the pring certainly was a risk it was a
it's a it's a right up there painting
and um it it doesn't it may be what you
call a trony it's a type but it has
there's more to it there than that and
it it becomes more oh there's a hand up
there it becomes much more um
so it has something and and his other
paintings don't always but sometimes
they do and I think also taking the um
camera obscura and creating I mean when
you saw how he went from his early stuff
to this whoosh it was just like a
completely different painter and I think
that would have been a risk at at the
time why because it's looking at it's
looking at the interior in a different
way it's the consum Perfection done
through a lens of genre painting which
everybody likes it's not risky at all
the Claudia civilist is risky it's a
lunatic it's the greatest commission he
could possibly have for the town hall he
blows it by because he's been reading
too many books in particular tacitus R
brand he thinks that the way the Dutch
should see themselves in the mighty town
hall is the barbaric custodians of
Freedom so you've been you know that
painting so that painting is done with a
kind of lunatic ferocity and he's
screwed as a result they take it down he
has to cut it up he's not paid a penny
for it that is what I call taking a risk
you just just said it was a failure so
as well where was the question yeah
there thank
you is this my question hello Simon I
want to ask about the use of
self-portraiture uh Tracy seemed to talk
about it as if it was a a negative thing
an egotistical thing what is your view I
mean out of 400 paintings any 90% were
not self-portraits right so to talk to
us about um it seemed to be Tracy was
attacking his use of self and I want you
to talk about that well I you know we
live in the age of the Hideous selfie
and you know the eggo manal formless
blog and so it it it's tempting an
acronis but you know I implore you to
think of
monten um that's to say when monten
invents the essay he invents it as a
form of self-scrutiny but the condition
of writing this the essay which by
definition when you essay something
you've tried something out was something
which was ruthlessly open-ended so
Rembrant when he's not simply trying on
his own face in order to to to a lot of
the early famous you know the famous
sort of shock surprise um kind of almost
clowning tiny etchings he's rehearsing
in the mirror the affetti the passion so
he can put them on you know sort of tra
he's right he's not putting his face on
but he can figure out what those
expressions like an actor are in his
history paintings as he goes on in this
beautiful rum of self-portraits at
National Gallery show all that drops
away and he becomes much closer to
montt's uh you know unsparing merciless
I mean what other there's only one other
painter I can think of Professor Maro
you'll correct me I know you will um of
this approximate period who does himself
as an old man and that other than
Leonardo actually I was thinking of
tishan but tishan of course does himself
as a kind of prince in profile a severe
Prince indeed because all the princes
have to kind a truckle to him but in
rem's world and Rembrandt's gener you
know I mean van dies early rubben does
not do himself as an old coder even
though he is for a Time Rembrant
explores the humility of the decomposing
flesh of yourself as an exercise in
profoundly moving self
chasing there are 80 images by R and
there's 40 paintings and then
and then with etchings and so on there's
about 8 that that's reason that's
significant in the history of no one has
taken it to that degree I'm just to put
it in context I mean we know that joro
was a kind of Pioneer in a sense but no
one quite pushes it to that level so the
case about Rembrandt's perceived
obsession with self-portraiture I think
is is made the question is I think that
comes from the questioner Peter
Rosengard if I'm not mistaken um is
about whether it's a good thing a Bad
Thing whether it's something that we
should castigate or or or salute I mean
do we feel us about van for example that
you know he was obviously this raving
egomaniac I think we did you someone
said yes I guess I find myself thinking
about why he was painting these
paintings were they for himself were
they for other people no um no he's
painting it as a kind of Paradigm of The
Human Condition you know really um
encased in his own likeness so this but
when he's actually in his Studio we know
it's not himself why does he why what
what's what's the is it he's using paint
as a kind of therapy as a kind of
looking into himself well I hate therapy
what about okay it's to 20th century a
term but can we call it self-examination
he's using it as self-examination but
what is what is that what do we make of
that how do we uh we're not involved in
it it's it's his own well you may not be
I'm intensely involved in WoW seems to
reveal more about our debers than it
does about the artist right question
yeah at the top there we go yeah um I've
got a rather broad question but do you
think one can really come to any kind of
objective decision I mean rbr or verir
or is it a question of character because
Tracy you talked about the verir being
more satisfying but personally to me uh
I think this lack of ambiguity is
actually a weakness I don't get a lot
from that I mean what do you think sorry
his lack of um you said that the verir
was more satisfying and to me that
suggests kind of lack of ambiguity which
perhaps the rembrand is more strong in I
think um actually there's loads and
loads of ambiguity in vermier and that's
why we go back to him again and again
the best masterpieces are the ones that
don't answer questions that you you go
back to again and again it's like
whenever I go to see girl the Pearl
earing wherever she was uh the last
couple of years or at now in the hag I
find it really hard to leave the room
and I think that's and that's true of
rembrand as well I think that's where
masterpieces come in as that you you
can't you're you're in almost like a
dialogue and you can't stop you can't
it's an unfinished conversation it's a
song that finish that doesn't finish
it's on the second to last chord and I
think that we can both agree that both
painters had those moments of greatness
where um you're you're there's a there's
a loss there's a lack of of resolution
and um and we come back to them again
and again can you stop being so
reasonable the whole point is ly Dees
in fact your point was that there was
mystery for you in verir to to an extent
that there wasn't in rembrand I'm not
saying you said that there was no no
mystery but your claim is that he's more
there's an element of mystery it's more
the amb the ambivalence the ambiguity
seems to ask more complex questions I
feel like when I look at a rembrand I
get it I know it's all there it's all
there and the process too because you
can see all the paintwork um verier is
much more controlled and and uh and I
feel like like I can actually because of
that I can go into it and and live in
there for a lot longer because there's
so much Mis there isn't any way of
resolving it and I feel like uh rembrand
he's he's laid more out there whereas
verir has held back
more is another question from the top
there yeah could you wait for the M or
come to the mic is that possible pass
the
mic we're going to have a the vote in
about three minutes so could someone
could get to the mic might that would be
great thank you very
much thank you I just want to go back to
the point we were talking about with
self-portraiture it's it's a question as
well as a
statement Rembrandt was ballsy enough to
go against the grain and perhaps not
always paint things that he'd get paid
for could not his efforts in
self-portraiture be just a historical
fact that he wasn't paid as much or he
didn't have people willing to sit for
him or he was more controversial and I
don't see it as self-absorbed in any way
but he was using a study that he had he
could consistently look at himself he
could consistently paint himself he was
funny with friends he lost and made them
I don't I couldn't possibly imagine
rembrand being a self-absorbed person
when his entire work was about un
uncovering and looking at the world I
would hardly ever think that he was a
self-obsessed man as a painter do you
think historically it's just having the
subject matter of himself constantly
that the reason that he painted so many
self-portraits very good question hold
the answer just for a second boxes are
going to go around now Now's the Time to
start voting we're going to keep taking
more questions then we're going to have
a wrap up but there is time for you to
vote now so boxes coming around one or
the other or the whole thing you don't
know I'll come to you in a minute let's
just deal with that question now so
woman there straight ahead y Hang on
we're still carrying on now so if you
could just be Qui Simon do you want to
respond to oh no I mean uh you're you're
right I I just want
to I would agree with everything you
said it's absolutely the case that he is
always there and who knows and there are
moments where you're absolutely right
it's difficult finding patrons and um he
he falls out so it's true I would just I
would just add that um and I I I'm about
to say this in a reviewer writing that
um
again this is a nightmare because we are
Tracy and I so friendly about this but
please everybody when you go to the show
um National Gallery um stop at the very
first etching which is the last
self-portrait etching R brand did in the
year of his when he lost his house in
1658 and it is as the lady up there says
I mean it's the it's of him but it's the
least self-absorbed it's a man his face
is collapsed into a sort of
indeterminate dumpling of misery and
little piglet eyes stare out at you from
this unrisen dumpling and it is the most
absolutely heartbreaking thing
you'll ever see this is the only debate
where someone says a painting space
looks like an indeterminate dumpling of
misery and you're supposed to be
sympathetic to that it's genius debting
genius can I add to that I think um
verir was also obsessed but it wasn't
with himself it was with a corner of his
Studio which he painted over and over
and over again and the way the light
came in and hit the person there and
sometimes it was used various members of
his family we think we're guessing um
and that would uh but it was it was he
was exploring light and color and that
was what he was doing with his obsession
it was rather than using himself great
there woman there you got the mic y y is
this on yeah so my question is really
for intelligence squar and the question
is what are we voting on
um Bravo well that's rather well but but
both Tracy and Simon made very
compelling arguments in favor of each
artist yes but what actually are we
voting on well I it's a very good point
I thought I tried to make the point that
actually in a debate when it's one
against another the parameters have to
be set by you so I think individually
you have to stare into your conscience
or your intellect or your knowledge and
say is it about the achievements of of
an artist who lived for 63 years whose
range and and and Heights are or is it
about the it's that the fire alarm goes
on or is it about the the the the
heights that one artist can H in a
particular painting that which would you
rather
steal
face she'll probably win that yeah
ladies and gentlemen this not this is
not a fire alarm it's just an exit
alarm um we just keep voting while this
goes
on another question another question
sure
you
Mich yeah Simon mention question there
question Simon mentioned the Yan sixth
house in Amsterdam it is open and you
just emailed for an
appointment so again what's the question
the Yang sixth house in just a point of
information Simon said the Yang sixth
house in Amsterdam is closed that open
and you just email for an appointment
and you go every morning brilliant okay
that's good that was useful thank you
very much right question the question
here and then a question at the back
we've got about five so so the voting's
almost over and I think that I can now
point out that from here Simon I think
I'm waving at you to your left I think
that the reason that you're so obsessed
with rembrand is in the words of um
private eye when I look at the painting
above you and I look at you are they by
any chance
related I I have a very good it is after
all all about
you
and that may win it no I just wanted to
ask a little question about patronage
because is what they paint not
determined slightly to an extent about
who their patrons are and obviously
every artist has their own particular
obsessions don't they so we're V we're
dealing with two very different people
but the body of work is surely very
different according to who their patrons
are because they don't just paint for
themselves they can't survive mhm yes uh
verier had a patron Ben ryvan and um a
wealthy man lived in Del and uh
certainly it's possible that the reason
he painted the way he did could have
been because uh his Patron liked it and
said do more um and and you can see what
happens to patronage the uh the late
painting uh of the vermier painting the
religious with the woman with her foot
on the globe and the eyes turned upward
that was painted painted as a commission
from the Jesuits and it was late in
vermeer's life he was under a lot of
stress he was in debt and he did it
probably pretty quickly and that is was
an example of how patronage can go
terribly wrong when you don't really get
to paint what you want interesting with
freeze the art fair on at the moment and
the idea about whether AR artists have
their eyes on the market both of these
artists ended up bankrupt yeah yeah I
mean REM bran I it's not to do with him
actually sticking his finger in the eyes
of the patron because I think he he was
not a rebel in that sense um but he was
there are documented problems that a man
called Diego dandada um brings takes
remember to court for um producing a
likeness of a woman young woman who we
think is probably we don't have sure his
daughter and insisting that rembrand
change it and finish it and rembrand
again we don't know the result rant said
oh yeah we'll take this to the the an
arbitration Committee of the Guild of St
Luke so what re always tries to do is to
transform the expectations of his
patrons whether it's the The Guild of
anatomy the surgeons in tul who had
never seen a painting like that that
doing the night watch was a staggering
risk it's not the kind of biopic version
as they all hated it it's not true they
didn't all hate it most of them loved it
um but he's always trying I mean it's
very clever and he tries to say now when
the shock of how radically different
from anything they could have expected
was but not necessarily unflattering now
you are so clever that's what you really
wanted and they say Yes actually you
know and it all goes wrong with the
Claudia civilist where the painting is
so ferocious and so wild and so
unprecedented in its intense roughness
clearly they said this is not anything
remotely like what painting is and you
finish it this is unfinished remember
says I get to decide what's finished or
not so all transactions you know
throughout the history of art from what
plyy tells us about you know appelles
and protogenes are transactions between
the Patron's expectations the artist's
irresistible itch to complicate that and
then who else is going to see it whether
it's a public painting or a private
painting or The Heirs have done it and
that's what makes it so organically
thrilling and un stable a process that's
a crucial point you very good point last
questions who hands up yeah so there
yeah um before we um came tonight I had
my mind made up already on verir um this
is a question uh I voted V verir before
um we came in and I've just voted verir
again um due to Tracy's compelling
arguments this is a question for the
both of you do you think vmir is more of
an artist's
artist no no absolutely not no actually
I think I think I think rembrand is an
artist artist he's uh it's because you
can see the process of a painting in
painting and whereas verier is much more
about the viewer I think that's what
I've been saying all along is it's it's
it's what I love about verier is not
necessarily the painter himself it's
about my relationship with the painting
with um with how I view the painting and
standing in front of it and where I
enter it where I where I am in it so
it's actually all about me not about
verier um whereas Rembrandt really is
all about Rembrandt and that makes him
but it's it's about the painter he's you
keep saying it Tracy it doesn't make it
so
well I suppose the answer really to your
question is it depends on the Artist
Artist Artist is a nice idea but
actually it I don't there's no such
thing many artists are Artist Artist but
it's a good point to throw into the
spanner of this debate even though
you've made your mind up right last
question gentlemen so further to what
Simon said said about rron that he's he
shows the emotion he's our friend you
know he can he empathizes with what
happens in his reality around him and
that that is a very modern way of making
art prir he transcends the daily reality
he works and works and works and that he
goes beyond time in his paintings and
the light is that it shows that silence
question so my question is what is the
Transcendence the the the the posit or
the the the reason why for me might win
what is in
Rembrant uh the same what what does he
have that transcends that reality and
that makes that Eternal Art and the
opposite in verir what is that Humane
side could you briefly elaborate great
we could almost build this in it's very
nice question we could almost build this
into closing remarks because we've got
about four five minutes we need to
finish bang on half past I think I'll
get the result then so can I ask you
that with that in mind to to integrate
that into your your closing remark Simon
Oh I
thought your question is whether verir
where is his
Humanity um I suppose I I think of him
as uh as being his arena is is domestic
and his his family really and that's
where his Humanity lies that he Paints
the same place and the same he he he
develops he he a a whole way of looking
at his his life through other people and
that's where his Humanity lies and that
is what draws Us in to to to make links
to that everyday
existence um as a writer I feel like
when I when I write a book when I finish
a book um it's not really complete until
I've handed it to somebody to read and
that's what completes it
um it's like a contract that I have with
the reader and and together we make a
complete object a compl complete thing
um and verir I think would understand
what I'm saying because he paints
something and then he puts it up for us
to come and look at it and we are we
enter it together with him and that's
where his humanity is it's with it's
with
him I and that is why while I admire
adire
rembrand as a wonderful painter I
actually love verir rather than love
rbrand I love rir and that's where the
humanity
is love and admiration nice ending Simon
yeah that's that's we profoundly do
differ on that because I admire verir
but he leaves ultimately leaves me cold
in his little cube of Crystal Light
rembrand to answer the question like the
very greatest artists in both literature
and
painting
um tells you what it's like to live in a
human
skin it tells you he addresses himself
he's prepared to be out there to address
himself to the conflicts of Love desire
hate belief passion
repentance ambition avarice he ENC
compasses the entire theater of what it
means to be a human and how to live in
the
world rembrand dares to take on how we
connect so I completely and totally
unpersuaded by Tracy I don't even
understand this issue of rembrand not
being Invitational There is almost no
painter that does not actually want you
to look back at him is the least closed
painter in the whole of the Barack and
many other centuries too he makes us
understand he gives us a new pair of
eyes about what it is like to be in a
business in a militia to be powerful to
be a beggar um to be an
adulterer um to be a good husband
rembrand touches us go and look at the
Jewish bride it's a painting about being
touched physically and touched
emotionally and it comes at us in the
most
spectacular dressing
of profoundly Rich complicated
gloriously beautiful paint look at the
bath
Sher the difference is that the
ultimately the picks his place his light
his models to be beautiful rembrand
could see
Beauty in
[Applause]
everything thank thank you both when
that alarm went off it was verir to
Eternity but actually we've managed to
hold that out um sorry sorry um the
results so there's been an 8% swing to
verir from the from before the database
up to 38% of you think he's won 6% of
you don't know 56% of you voted for
rembrand so the
winner is
[Applause]
[Music]
rembrand